Okay,
should be live here.
Let me real quick see if I can change
the um
the Twitch stream
category,
work.
Nice.
live.
We've got
It's only 10 somehow. I thought I was
slow this morning. It's only 10.
You have lots and lots to do today.
ideally with the microphone in a
position that makes reasonable sense.
Didn't get the best sleep last night.
Didn't run the best 10k this morning.
Didn't lift the heaviest weights, but we
got it done.
We'll get better sleep tonight.
For now, though, I feel reasonably
rested enough to um to tackle this.
um provided
we take this
reasonably.
So let's first of all
Okay. So, we got 500 experiments off of
this.
We got 500.
We're going to
So now we have our logs for two ends.
Actually,
you know what? We don't actually we
don't even have to think about this yet.
There's no thinking required yet, right?
Um
there's no reason to bother.
Let's do the non-thinking work first as
a warm-up.
We'll do the analysis from last night.
Blackjack puffer going well. Expect a
PR.
Okay, cool.
Thanks, Anish.
I assume Puffer just like wrecks that,
right?
Actually, Puffer will probably cheat.
Um,
it depends if it's uh if the way you set
it up, if it's a full shuffle, like if
it can count cards or not.
I don't what's understand what's going
on but all the best. This is
reinforcement learning research done
live. Um, we are currently working on
a type of exploration algorithm
that uses the ability of simulators to
jump to any particular state that you've
previously seen.
Uh this is intended to be a two-eek
research sprint and in literally the
first uh in literally the first day we
got state-of-the-art
implemented state set on Inferno
protein actually prefers both. Yeah.
Volo. So, um, the bar for this,
can it do
can state sets match a manual
curriculum? I'd be very happy if it
could do that.
Like, let's say that with no curriculum,
you kind of just get wrecked
and then this thing matches manual
curriculum.
That's already good.
Poker is my dad. Yeah. I I just thought
that that would be very funny to do, you
know?
Like he plays your classic Holdem like
just constantly.
Um
I thought it'd be pretty funny to see.
See, look. The model's better than you
at the game in 30 seconds.
That's what I'm trying to figure out.
Yeah, Val. Um, there's still lots of
ablations and things to run, mind you.
Sweep for 12 hours. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We
actually I'm pulling This is what I'm
doing right now. I ran sweeps on mazes
and I'm about to pull uh the results
Swept is pretty fleshed out, so it's not
going to be easy to beat. If it does, it
would be huge. That's the point.
How' it work out yesterday? Uh, we like
we nailed it, Tim.
At least I think so. We're here. We're
going to pull the results right now.
This is not going to have the uh the
pram at first, but we'll do this to
start.
Uh, do we have the stupid cryp crypto
spammers again?
Ignore that. There's no token
casual algo. I mean, it's not casual.
Like, I've been thinking about this
algorithm for months,
but it was in an afternoon, which is
pretty cool.
This is laggy, which is weird. It's not
supposed to be laggy.
Okay, so we've got base
Uhoh. Huh. Is it Is it the same?
Doesn't look like it cuz look, there's
only a few points.
Okay. So this is interesting. Look at
this.
This is solving.
So this is numbum layers.
H.
We really should put the number of
parameters on here, shouldn't we?
This is definitely solving with way
shallower nets.
Like presumably he has enough money to
not have to give a [ __ ]
the algo or the end of uh it is the
algorithm but it's assuming state sets.
So it's an end of change to support an
algorithm change.
Okay, hang on. Wait. This is
this is still quite a big difference,
isn't it?
I don't believe that the base algorithm
solves this.
Okay, this is interesting, right? Look
at this.
So, with the base,
no, there's no way that this is solving
right with barely any prioritization.
and then look we basically it's all
highly prioritized
over here.
You know, we should also just include
the CL frack, shouldn't we? Let's just
do that real quick.
Okay.
So,
get more. I mean,
I would assume he made a [ __ ] ton at
Tesla already now.
Like, I would assume he doesn't need
more cash.
I think the guy's just gotten kind of
loopy and thinks Anthropic's actually
doing stuff correctly. Like Enthropic is
the out of touch company. You go there
when you're completely [ __ ] out of
touch.
State buffer size versus PF.
Let's do
uh what's this? E5.
E5. Wait. Huh?
I didn't think we could go that low with
this.
Oh, no. E5. That's 280K.
Okay. Okay. So, anything like 280K plus
is fine. It looks like
actually looks like smaller buffer is
kind of better here.
280. Okay. So, that's cool to know.
it's kind of interesting actually if you
look at it this way.
If you give this thing access to
curriculum,
it doesn't look for the solutions that
don't use the curriculum. So, you would
think that that would mean the
curriculum is pretty immediately useful.
Like look at this. Anything this is like
40% plus of states.
Most of the runs are very low
prioritization.
What was our default on this?
Would it have been like this point out
here?
I think it's probably like one of these.
Like probably this point would have been
our baseline.
And they're definitely some weird things
going on here. Let's just do
Okay, wait. Actually, this is fun,
right? So we have
what these points represent these are
all experiments.
This is a morning analysis of overnight
experiments and trying to see what we
figure out from
like the data is much messier
from the um the non-curriculum learning
one
but then somehow
according to this it's finding like
solves
we can just go run this real Right.
We have to go watch some policies, I
think, cuz that's kind of ridiculous.
I don't know if I believe that. Oh,
also, no, we know that this thing is
good. Okay, I I forgot to tell you guys
this. So, let me explain something. Let
me sort of like put into perspective
what is going on here. Um,
so yesterday we ran some initial
experiments
on uh very hard mazes and it looked like
we were just crushing crushing crushing
the baseline, right? Um, I ran
hyperparameter sweeps overnight for both
of them and the curriculum learning
method is very good, but it looks like
the non-curriculum learning method can
still solve the task.
and it can solve the task like way
better than expected. It should not
remotely be able to solve that task. Um,
but then I remember last night I also I
ran this on 2048 and we got a new
state-of-the-art on 2048 as well
and 2048 is like a very high confidence
task for us. So, I mean, it would seem
to me that there is still something
here.
Like, there's something very good here,
but it's a little complicated what's
going on.
I think that's probably what it is, Tim.
I think that Puffer 4 is just really,
really good. And like you just need some
stupidly hard problems
to even test things because once you run
a hyper prim sweep like Puffer 4 kind of
just solves a lot of stuff you would
expect it to not be able to solve.
Yeah. But this is right here. This is
state-of-the-art on 2048 under after the
new end fixes on 40 and it's in way less
time as well. This is like a third of
the time as the previous best solution
and a few hundred points higher.
And mind you, this is actually with a
smaller model as well. I think there is
definitely something to this um this
algorithm we've come up with.
All right. So,
uh let's first start
hang on.
It looks like this was here before.
This is Okay, it's the map. The starting
size. Fine.
recent 248. Yes, I do. I have the one
from 40 and I if you compare on the
website here, I guess I can bring it up
while this thing trains.
Okay. So, if you look at 2048 here
and you go to score
in 19 66 seconds, it wasn't a third of
the time. I guess we'd be like right out
here.
So we would have this point would be
near the other points that are like 12k
score and we are 500 points higher than
our best ever run.
Oh wait maybe okay admittedly I think
this might have been on a 4090.
It might be the same amount of time but
I do think it's a smaller model as well.
I've noticed that.
Yeah, look at this. So, this is a
uh this is a 10 million parameter policy
and we just did it with a 3 million
parameter policy.
Was there a bug? Uh, there was a while
ago like with the way that we were
handling stuff. We had one of like the
uh the 2048
um al there like there's a community of
people that write scripts on 2048 and
they said like, "Hey, you've got this
thing with the way you're handling
resets." It was a subtle difference. Um
so we changed that and it made it a bit
harder.
Okay, so this gets us 41.
So that's interesting, right? This is
this parameter set was supposed to get
us 47,
but it actually only gets us 41.
It's still ridiculous though that you
can do that.
I guess we could make the benchmark
bigger.
Let's see if that's likely to do
anything.
Does it make sense to make the benchmark
bigger?
I mean, it kind of doesn't. It kind of
doesn't
We should definitely weight that result
quite heavily.
Oh, well this is interesting.
We're at 128 horizon, aren't we?
Hang on.
512.
Wait. Um, hey guys, this thing is now
sweeping.
It's sweeping longer horizons
to solve this.
And actually the best data points we
have significantly are
at shorter horizon. It's using
curriculum.
It is noisy though. It's quite close. I
don't want to make I want to make sure
we have clear trends actually out here.
Look, it's all the some of these good
base runs are all the way out here.
That's cool. We're doing very long
horizon stuff. That's a tiny number of
steps as well. So like we just got
massive sample efficiency somehow at the
same time.
I mean look clearly puffer for solving
the task in a minute would mean that we
don't have a hard enough problem.
I mean, this seems like a crazy hard
problem to me.
What was this one that I grabbed? Cuz I
grabbed like a reasonable point.
Okay, look, this is still pretty highly
prioritized.
obs and action spaces. Um, action is
just like move left, right, up, down.
OBS is a uh a crop of the nearby tiles.
Let me think about if this task is
really if I've set this thing up
optimally.
So, I mean the point of um the point of
this update, right? Like the motivating
example of this is really long horizon
tasks where when you fail, you go all
the way back to the start. That's like
the classic example.
I actually maybe the syiness of mazes
makes it bad.
I mean, I wouldn't be surprised if it's
just like Puffer 4 is learning a really
good general maze solving algorithm
quickly,
Okay. So, I think we need to just think
harder about
um
about tasks then that we use for this.
What's like um we need some sort of nice
progressive task.
The simplest form of this This is just
like entering a code, right?
So the environment is just um
you have a code.
You have to enter the digits of a code.
As soon as you get a digit wrong, you go
back to the All right.
Yeah, cuz then there's no syiness in the
structure you can exploit.
That would be like um
That's a simple enough environment
codeex can implement it.
I'm trying to think if there's anything
I'm I'm missing here with that.
I think we try it.
Let's just go see real quick.
cuz we can't use this end, this
incremental end.
I mean, as crazy as it is that this
thing is solved.
the horizon like the the increased
horizon's very encouraging to me though
cuz like look
without the horizon before
it's very bad.
Wait, how does this make sense?
Isn't the baseline
I thought I had a baseline end?
that should have done better than this
with only 64 horizon
unless
Oh no. Maze is 256 horizon. Okay, I
hadn't noticed that.
That's actually a really cool thing then
from Puffer 4.
Okay.
We'll have to merge in those um those
new kernel changes then from the guys
that have optimized this for us.
Does that sound like a reasonable
environment proposal though? Just like a
passcode environment.
We basically like puffer is so good at
this point that we just need to give it
fewer things to work with. I think that
makes sense.
And then if it does better on this then
it's still um like that solves a
problem, right? And we can sweep it on
other ends.
specific ends.
Do you really care?
I mean, you go train that LLM with
millions of dollars of compute and we
train our models in seconds or minutes
on one GPU. Hell.
I'm trying to think if there's a better
environment that I could use for this.
I mean, this is obviously a dumb
synthetic task.
Um,
to be fair, I've had versions of this
passcode end before.
I had never actually thought of this as
a um as like a state set test, but I
think it's a good on.
We'll go play with this to see if this
is um correct or not.
Super simple end, right? 150 lines. I
think it could be even shorter.
Yeah. And then this success we also
don't need.
We'll refactor that. But let me get this
in initial thing first.
This task intentionally does not require
memory.
kind of funny that it actually realized
that it should do Yes.
Ah,
forgot about that.
Would
Okay.
Well, this thing trains super fast,
God damn, man. It's like keeps adding
this stupid extra character at the top
of my file.
Dude, this does worse. Oh, no. It
matches.
Arguably, at the very least, I could run
a quick sweep on this, right? Like, this
wouldn't take very long.
Not sweeping the mini batch sizes and
stuff's a little iffy.
Hopefully we have checks on this. I
think we do.
All right,
that'll do.
We'll give this a quick sweep.
Uh, presumably this doesn't take very
long.
We'll start thinking about some other
things as well.
make sure that it still works.
And um
okay,
we're starting to get experiments coming
in here.
Hopefully, it'll run longer stuff. We
will see.
I'm going to go use a restroom real
quick. I'll And um also grab my uh my
vitamins for the day. So, we'll let this
get a few runs in and then we have still
quite a bit of stuff to do, right?
Let's take a quick look before I I do
that.
Yeah. So, I think that we're here right
now, right? Dedicated test environments.
We have some good initial results.
Um, we definitely need some stuff on
test environ. We need this test
environment first.
We get signs of life on this and then we
uh we can consider algorithmic ablations
from there.
for puffer five.
Let me make sure these experiments are
going. Um, you know, one other thing I
got to do real quick.
Folks still watching, um, do Star Puffer
on GitHub. It's free.
It actually helps us out a ton. Um, it
means I have to spend less time
advertising my stuff to companies and
then companies to come to me for
professional stuff and I get to spend my
time here streaming.
Okay, we already have 200 experiments on
password, so that was quick. Um,
And 28 seconds as well. Okay, we have to
relaunch these with something harder.
Like I'm genuinely having a hard time
coming up with tasks that aren't just
[ __ ] that Puffer doesn't solve at
this All right.
Okay. With 256.
Um, I will I actually I will not be
surprised if this still solves.
If it solves in 45 million steps though,
I we just have AGI. Whatever. Like you
don't even need Puffer 5. It's just AGI.
Well, do you understand why this
password environment is ridiculous?
It's like guess the password, right? And
I'll tell you if the leading digits are
correct, but then you have to re-enter
the whole thing every time.
So for like 256, right? To get your one
bit of information, you have to go
through 256 steps.
So, I'm basically just trying to come up
with environments where like you have to
redo all your progress every time you
make a mistake because that's the ideal
case for state sets.
Did it just cast a fireball? True. It's
not AGI until it cast fireball.
Let me go get my vitamins.
All right.
1 mil SPS with 4K agents. No, it's way
more than 1 mil SPS with 4K agents, man.
We can hit 10 mil with 4K agents.
Maybe higher than that.
And yes, Puffer is a research lab. I'd
argue it's the best research lab in this
specific type of thing.
Let's stream all the dev right here.
It's a fun time.
All right. So,
score of 46 so far.
Yeah, 46 so far is the best on this 10
mil with 8K agents. We hit 20 mil. That
was the um the main result from puffer
uh 4. Our public release. We solve
breakout in about 4 seconds
with 8192 agents and um a small but
non-trivial architecture model
number one I mean number one research
lab in like tabularasa RL yeah
you can go ahead and compare um puffer
to other things out there if you'd like
particularly if you care a lot more
about like infrastructure structure and
um you know large scale testing and that
sort of thing. We don't come up with the
fanciest like you know the fanciest
ideas or any sort of crazy math or
anything but we make things work
incredibly well.
Hey Jess. So um the finding from
overnight was that the maze task was too
easy because the curriculum uh model
shredded it but uh with enough tuning
the baseline was also able to solve the
same task and uh the results are kind of
comparable. I think what's happening is
just it's learning the substructure of
mazes very quickly on the smaller ones
and um then there's just not really much
to differentiate between those two
models. So essentially it was just a bad
choice of tasks for this um this one.
There were some advantages. It looks
like there were some reasons to prefer
the curriculum version over the other
one still. Um but we just need a better
task. So I have this new task. The task
is called password. The way it works is
there is a 256digit password and you
start entering digits. Every time you
get a digit correct, you get a reward.
As soon as you get a digit wrong, you
get a negative reward and the entire
thing resets. So essentially, you know,
you're you are forced to repeat the
entire trial up to where you failed.
This should be a good task for state
sets, I would imagine. Um,
it's actually kind of funny when I think
about it, right? Like in order for state
sets to be better here, we'd have to set
very low horizon.
So, I don't know. We'll see. We'll we'll
start with this and we'll see how it
goes.
Does anybody else have any ideas for
like similar types of tasks we could use
that would be simple to implement and
would be better in any way? Like the
point of state sets, right? Well, there
are a lot of points to state sets. It's
a very powerful curriculum algorithm,
but the cleanest, easiest to see
description of why you have to have
state sets is for longunning problems
where making a single mistake makes you
start from the beginning.
That's like the most obvious use case
for it. Now, I expect what's going to
happen is if we tune this to thing to be
very good on that case, then we're going
to just see it going to it's going to
just be better across the board on a lot
of ends. Um,
and we'll be able to measure all that.
But we need a good clean task setup
first.
Puffer LLM.
Nah, we don't have any puffer LLMs.
We do real science here.
Okay, there it is. It's It's starting to
learn here. So, oh, come on. 16 seconds.
Yes, 16 seconds. It solved 80 uh length
73.
Cool. Well, all right. Let's look at the
main stuff we've got on Puffer 5. And
I'll kind of just talk through this.
It'll take a while to get a reasonable
enough sweep uh for the baseline, I
suppose. So,
refactoring environments to support
setable state. Honestly, as long as we
have a before and after for each of
these codecs can literally do this. The
bigger ends, I'll have to make sure it
doesn't make a mess, but like this is a
very, very simple refactor.
Multi-agent integration. This is done
for fixed numbers of agents per ends. It
turns out that the drive environment
could be modified to have a fixed number
of agents per n. There not that many
cases where you need um variable.
I mean it would be nice to have I
suppose but like
it would be nice to have but this is
just a pain in the ass and I don't feel
like messing up the code base. I'm going
to say no on this for now. I think this
is not worth it unless we have a really
really important N that needs this
um dedicated test environment.
The password M should cover this I would
suppose. I think like password on its
own if this if these experiments work
like this should be the cleanest
possible test case. It doesn't require
memory. It doesn't require anything else
other than uh state sets
solved versus remaining exploration
problems. So yeah, um I said I think
that this solves curriculum learning. I
this does not solve all of exploration.
So I think that the remaining thing is
going to be
uh environments that or algorithm that
gets good state coverage. So, like let's
say we just delete all the rewards.
Um,
do you cover states? Like do you cover
all the states or whatever.
The state coverage is a remaining
problem. I don't know if I want to start
that,
you know. I don't know if I want to
start on that.
I don't think that needs to be part of
puffer five.
Um, I think we keep puffer five nice and
small and concise.
Ablations and sweeps. We're already
doing that. So, right. But the main the
main ablations I have in mind, um,
we need to know how big of a experience
buffer is required across different
problems. And we need to think about the
efficiency of sampling
parkour course. Yeah, that like exactly
Jess curriculum learning is in
supervised learning. How it works in RL
exams make it progressively more
difficult. Yeah. So it's um it's a whole
class of method sounds. You can do
curriculum learning by modifying your
training environment specifically to
give it this like easier than harder and
then harder thing adaptively or fixed.
the algorithm that we're working on
here. It's intended to be a much more
powerful and general method. Um, it only
requires that your environment have
setable state, which if you're building
your own enviration
from Puffer 5 is that this is actually
not a big restriction.
Um,
and it works by letting you jump right
to portions of the environment where
you're currently having difficulty or
you're currently learning a lot. And it
does this fully automatically.
So that should be very powerful and
we're investigating that at the moment.
Is there a paper? So this is a
combination of very very high level what
was done in go explore
uh prioritized experience replay and
advantage filtering from go explore.
There are a couple like prioritized
level replay type ideas in here but it's
very heavily modified and it's done at
the level of trajectory segments not
levels.
So it's arguably the biggest inspiration
is go explore and then it's a
combination of many other techniques but
it's like the specific combination of
those techniques was already sort of in
puffer 4 and even three so it flowed
quite naturally.
Yeah, I I they've already had a million
people ask me about that today. Yes,
I have a very very strong suspicion that
um a lot of the people that you see
being successful that suddenly kind of
go off the deep end um I think that SF
just has a really big acid problem.
That's kind of my guess cuz I don't know
how the [ __ ] else you explain this. I
guess it could also just be like giant
SF echo chamber.
I guess that's also kind of a simpler
explanation,
but who the hell knows?
I'd like to I prefer to stay away from
both.
Okay, ablations. Let let's let me talk
through some of the experiments here.
So,
the main performance impact right now,
um, the main performance problem with
Puffer 5.
I don't know who the [ __ ] this is. Um,
the main performance problem with Puffer
5 is simply sampling from the giant
replay buffer. So, we either come up
with a way to make the replay buffer
smaller or we make the sampling more
efficient.
Yeah, I don't really have a good
solution to the Twitter thing. Sounds
like because I have to put stuff out on
Twitter every so often. This is where I
get my clients and all of my brand stuff
from.
But it's truly awful. And I am I am both
happier and more productive when I'm on
that less.
I have a solution to YouTube on your
phone. At least get one of these. You'll
never watch YouTube again.
Good luck watching YouTube on a Kindle
screen.
Yeah, it's too easy to turn that off.
And also, you can still watch videos on
grayscale.
This like the entire screen flashes and
like warps and screws up if you try to
play a video.
It's like intentionally shitty. And also
the keyboard, it's like such a pain in
the ass. I barely use my phone. It's
great. I the actually the only thing I
use my phone for a lot now is audible
which is exactly what I Huh?
Okay. So, it's either smaller buffer or
faster sampling. Um,
let's think about this.
So,
the size of the buffer determines how
long a round a sample is for you to make
use of it.
The fewer fresh environments that you
have,
the slower it fills up.
I mean at that point you just don't have
a phone Volo
which like life goals not having to own
a phone that sounds pretty great.
All I would really need is a player for
books.
Yeah, I mean realistically right like
let's say
it depends on the fraction of CLMs as
well.
Let's say that you have a thousand fresh
environments.
It's going to be on the order of like
tens to low hundreds of millions of
steps backward reaching.
And like I suppose that's reasonably
powerful.
I think rather than keeping a massive
buffer,
the most profitable thing for us is
going to just be to figure out
what stuff needs to go into the buffer
in the first place.
We could just put like the top advantage
segments in
10k.
If we could get a buffer with only 10k
starting states, right?
I would like I'd believe that you could
do a lot with that
because the thing is we're not really
using prioritized experience replay in
the same way anyways.
Okay. So, like
there's stuff we can do here. We
definitely need the we need like a clean
benchmark to start with though, for
sure. Let's see how this thing is going.
Jesus Christ, man. 219.
At least it's taking
186 mil steps.
343 possib. Okay. We'll check back on in
this in a little bit once I've gone
through the rest. So, we did this single
compilation unit. Cleaning up kernels
and stuff is going to depend on what we
do for the rest of this. Um,
I really want to keep 5 like as
concentrated as possible of an update.
So, I think I'm going to help Spencer
with some of the selfplay and then we
just do a little bit of basic science
type stuff.
This is super simple. This is a bunch of
experiments, but like this is like
nothing to implement.
Oh yeah. Whatever happened to Aurora
or Jess?
That's what it was called, right? the
new optimizer thing.
You guys were working on this at one
point, right?
Inferno. See? Yeah, that's the thing.
You don't do um
lost your speed fix.
Well, I'd like to have that just so I
can play with it. So, you don't go test
the thing on Inferno.
Um,
you test it on like our core stable ends
like 2048 is a good thing to sweep it
All of these
are like easy to play with from stable
code though
be a conflict flag. Um once you're done
with like the current inferno stuff,
absolutely. I would very much like to
know whether you have anything with the
state sets on the thing. Uh also it is
possible that I end up changing the
state set algo quite a bit. Like it's
going to depend a lot on this password
and
Yeah. See, it's still doing better. This
is It's just gone up.
It's funny to me that this gets such a
high gamma for what's essentially a
one-step credit assignment problem.
I mean, I guess the other thing is
there's room for quite a bit of basic
science in Puffer 5.
Like I would like to understand a lot
better
the remaining gaps.
Like what ends are still hard for us
actually.
Bandit problem.
Um, memory test,
I guess there are a few like simple M's
we could come up with.
understanding
the model has to guess the password.
Yeah, I can explain the password end
again real quick. So the password end
works like this. There's one singular
password. It doesn't change. It's a
fixed length. It's length 256.
You start at the very beginning. You
don't observe the password. You guess a
digit. If you get it right, you can
observe it goes into the observation
like that. Yes, this is the correct
digit and um you get a reward. then you
guess the next digit so on and so forth
until you get one wrong. When you get
one wrong, observations get wiped, whole
thing resets
but to the same password. So the idea is
you have to try out digits and like as
soon as you make a mistake, you have to
reenter the whole password. So in order
like the optimal way to do this right is
you just try every digit.
um you try every digit for each number
and
um like the annoying thing about it is
you have to re-enter everything every
time. So it takes way way way longer
than if you could just try the digits
individually.
And this is where state sets come in
because with state sets you can jump
partway through the problem and you
should be able to dramatically shorten
the um the amount of time that's
required.
Okay, I like the idea of doing some
sanity ms.
you don't need to remember. So, the
password end does not require memory
because you can observe all the digits
you've gotten so far.
Arguably, you could do slightly better
at it if you remembered the um whatever
the like you've tried already on the
current digit, but because you're doing
this thing massively in parallel
anyways, that's less relevant.
Like you have to realize when I make
test environments like this, they're not
meant to be realistic or fair.
They're meant to expose specific flaws
or like specific edge cases in the
current algorithm. That's it.
Reinforcement learning in form of what?
welcome.
You do have to remember the password,
don't you?
Right. But you only have to remember one
step, right?
Yeah. You don't have to remember the
whole sequence.
You only have to remember
I like that. I think this is good.
Anything else that we're missing?
Uh we have not gotten any additional
any additional progress on this
This is Ian's paper which is like
delightful policy gradients dude.
Well, I shouldn't be so negative on it.
I mean, he's trying this stuff. I just
don't think metric makes much sense.
And this was a good attempt for the time
as well.
Yeah. Yeah. Now, this was actually a
reasonably good thing.
The tasks are a little too arbitrary,
See this is wrong right here cuz this is
not a memory test. This is also a credit
assignment test.
We fixed that with the thing I just did.
You bought a tiny box. I bought two.
We have two tiny boxes at Puffer.
They've got 64090s each.
They were uh 25k a piece.
So decent pricing back then
Uh, yeah, this one is stupid.
This one is very stupid.
I just want to see if there are any good
environments in here that I haven't
thought about.
This is trivial. This is trivial.
This is trivial.
This is reward scaling is a separate
issue. We could look actually that is
something we wanted to look into.
But this is not a good formulation of
it.
Uh Muhammad, you're listening to morons
that are trying to sell you things.
is this credit
credit assignment.
had to learn something.
I mean, what are you interested in?
Right?
Like, I'm not going to tell anybody
who's not interested in dev to go do dev
cuz you'll just be a terrible dev.
Like I'm not the person to ask on like
what's a stable job I can do that makes
All the scripted opponents get one shot.
Know you're unemployed. I'm not
unemployed. Volo
buffer has contracts.
And I get to do all sorts of cool
research with it.
Learning to memorize which digit to
place. Yeah. Crit. But like the thing
with the password and Oh, actually
speaking of which, are we ready? Whoops.
Whoa. out of memory.
Oh, yeah. Look, two of the GPUs just
died.
Huh. Interesting.
Okay, so apparently we do have some
things to fix with that.
All founders are unemployed. Fair
enough.
Tax right off on the boxes. Yeah, of
course. Jess, any of the equipment we do
is um
like any of the equipment you purchase
for use for your company.
that is the uh the new sweep going.
We'll see what this does.
Yeah, I don't think uh I don't think
this is really any different. All right,
we can ignore this one.
Why do you need to cut calories?
Um, I mean, just like um more casual
training while I was finishing Puffer 4
and not wanting to lose muscle. You
know, you gain some fat when you're not
training quite as much as you normally
do if especially if you're trying not to
lose your muscle and strength.
So, no big deal. We I also PR the bench,
so wasn't bad. No big deal. Easy 10
pound cut.
And um I'm basically just having like a
bagel sandwich and maybe a soup um after
my run at like 10:00 a.m. 9 or 10 a.m.
And then I have a big bowl of soup for
dinner and that's it.
It's like a hardy soup, but still.
Yeah, see, but you're probably doing it
smart. I just like, you know, cut
calories by a thousand plus and say,
"Yeah, sure. That'll work.
I'm feeling hungry. I don't really like
I don't really get that hungry. It
doesn't or I do but it doesn't bother me
now. Cutting is just not that hard for
me.
I mean, I try not to get 20 lbs up from
whatever weight I want.
Like the 16 lbs I cut last summer was
some pretty nutty circumstances.
You know, I guess so is
kind of the next task I'm super excited
about, right?
As a benchmark.
Like that's a really good why the hell
can't we solve that task?
Yeah, I definitely don't just fast.
That's um not a good way to keep muscle
and strength.
And I'm also not just like not eating
and doing nothing, right? I'm still
running 10k per day and doing some
lifts.
Well, we don't have a ton of runs yet
and we're we're only to 90. It's not
great so far.
I'll be back.
Oh, look. It's already better.
Okay. Well, we'll see how this goes. So,
this looks like a reasonable set of
things though for puffer puffer five.
This is nice sanity.
I mean, we'll get a better set of levels
for it.
Yeah, we'll get a better set of levels
Maybe we'll relativize the obs.
won't save.
Okay, I guess we can think about the um
we can assuming that we get some
reasonable thing out of state sets
which seems very very likely here given
the earlier results.
Um,
the ablation that we would run on
prioritized experience replay. There are
not that many of them.
We'd basically just take the replay
buffer, right?
And instead of adding everything to the
replay buffer,
we would either sample or add like top K
or whatever based on advantage.
I think that would be reasonably simple
to check.
That would be reasonably simple to
check. So if this works on password,
then we have the next experiment to run.
It'll require us to implement some
things. If this doesn't work on
password,
well then I think we have to go revisit
some of the algorithm design choices
because it really should.
It actually would be very very odd if it
didn't work here, right?
I guess arguably it would be the um like
the important sampling correction could
be off, right?
Oh, so we would just reimplement the
explore beta thing.
We'd reimplement that annealing. Maybe
actually the CL frack analing is the
easiest one.
Yeah, CL frackening is the easiest and
just sweep that.
That's guaranteed to be okay. So, we
have a plan. We've got a plan.
Uh we're at 126. And how many runs?
And this is
60k steps.
Let's see if we see any difference so
far, I suppose.
on Chris Ola?
Huh? Where's this come from?
I haven't thought about that guy since
interpretability work like many years
ago.
another one to turn.
That's basically the same as um well
actually I think that's worse than the
password environment because the thing
is you'll kind of just quickly get the
gist of the task and then there's not
really any more curriculum problem to
it.
Enduro is sort of like that.
Okay. Oh. Uh, this base.
Well, that's not super encouraging.
So far, it's doing better without the
CL,
though. It's not very far into the
sweep.
Interesting.
So, I guess it's possible that the
inefficiency of the implementation is
what's boring it.
Have to let this go longer. And um
in the meantime,
Andre. Yeah, I don't know what he's
doing
on sweep
over from 3 0. Well, sweep has a whole
bunch of stuff in 40. Pepper
10 possible. I can just make it digits
one to four if I want.
Found it yesterday.
Yeah, I don't know about him personally.
I just know a lot of the anthropic
people are really out of touch. But I
kind of just ignore any and all
communications from that company other
than just the model benchmarks.
Yeah, Jess was doing that as well.
Hassan,
Now, that's not going to be a good test
for CL. It's like
you want something very self-contained
when you're doing these types of things.
BF-16.
Thank you very much, Spencer. I'll we'll
be merging that in shortly. We're
getting some really weird stuff with um
the CL at the moment. I think something
is quite wrong with it. We still have
the soda result from yesterday. Um, but
I need to fix some things.
Yeah, I think what we do is we let the
current one run
and then we do the we do annealing out
the CL ratio.
And then annealing out the CL ratio
should give us
if we're biasing the training with C
with CL that would fix it, right?
Well, something is screwy because
state buffer size.
Okay. So, I guess it's possible that the
sampling is just really slow.
You see there is a peak seal frack.
I do wonder if this needs to be annealed
I think this is going to be a pretty
robust set of um experiments.
Um, so I made a uh a new test end for
curriculum Spencer because I think what
was happening with
uh with the maze env is just like the
agents were very quickly learning a
general maze solving strategy.
And then at that point it like it
doesn't really matter the size as much.
Um so with this end of it's a very
strict test of
of exploration in the sense that
you enter a password one digit at a
time. You have to guess each digit and
as soon as you get one wrong you go back
to the start and you can also observe
all the digits you've entered thus far.
So the idea is with this one you very
very clearly have to go back to the
start every time and I mean if
curriculum does not work here there's
something wrong.
So got the goal is to get a very strong
result on this and then see um when we
sweep everything else with this what
happens.
it does seem weird to me that like
biasing the data like that is a thing.
Like this CL frack here, right?
Oh, what? Wait, why is it all at 0.9?
Why does this start at one and then go
to 0.9?
Oh, okay. It's just the log screwing up.
Now, this is fine.
Yeah. So right here, the fact that this
is peaking at like X
So yeah, I think even if it's not going
to be the final
approach here,
um
we're going to need to anneal this
fraction.
Also the state buffer size is being
screwy.
This doesn't make sense. I think we just
wait until we have a little bit more
data and then we analyze this and then
we run the other one. And if this takes
some time today, it's kind of fine
because we sort of figured out
everything else in the meantime.
Um, so once we have these results, we
basically should just be able to plow
through everything.
I suppose we could just like shitty
codeex implementation the other ms um
just to start with while I'm waiting for
stuff.
I don't hate that idea. Yeah.
Yeah, I think we just explicit
curriculum
You don't want a negative one penalty.
They get
conservative, don't they?
yard Aurora. Okay, great. I have lots of
nice PRs now. It seems
we're going to wait until we have this
current thing stable. Of course,
we're at 144. Yeah, this is not doing
very well now, is it?
It's very concerning that the um
curriculum doesn't work him initially on
this task.
Well, actually, it should be able to
just set the CL frack to zero if it's
bad. So, in some sense, this would have
to just be a sweep failure, wouldn't it?
Makes me think it's worth investing time
on the sweep stuff.
find objective.
Now, we're doing something quite
different with the CL stuff right now.
Well, I mean, this definitely doesn't
make sense, right? Because
it could just push this yellow frack
down to zero.
In some sense, this is a sweep failure.
makes it worth um a lot more like this
means like a lot more it's it's worth
putting more effort into sweeps I'd say.
I just have so many hypers now.
That makes no sense to me.
My experiments, uh, we're going to do
500 each on password Spencer.
I suspect that we just have some small
flaw. Um, I have I have follow-ups to
this.
I think it's the case that we know that
there's stuff in this algorithm, but
then there just some failure cases
that we need to handle.
They should not be building for this
long.
This is to be clear this is just a
separate thing. This is not for um
H.
That's funny.
In discreet or continuous? Do it in
discreet. Spencer. Continuous has been
sketchy lately and I don't want to
conflate. Like I don't want to have
stuff screwing up because of that
Uh,
yeah.
We're running experiments at the moment.
We got to finish. There's something
wrong with it. I mean, we have the soda
result on 2048.
But I think we have um I think we're
going to need to make some small changes
to the algorithm. I think there's some
silly failure modes.
Yeah. See, this thing is still getting
better,
but this is going to end up
underperforming. I'm pretty sure the uh
the baseline.
No big deal. It's a pretty quick sweep
to run.
So,
I see that there's a like if I look at
this,
I'll show you.
Oh, come on, man.
Oh, wait.
if I look at the fraction of
environments that are being used for
curriculum learning, there's this peak
at like 6 and it gets worse if you go
higher.
Um, so I think what's happening here,
there's this sampling bias that's caused
by setting environments to be using the
curriculum. And the other thing that's
suspicious
is the value that it's finding for
explore alpha is way too small.
It's basically trying to avoid using too
much of the curriculum,
which I suspect is it's trying to
balance using the curriculum with
biasing the data.
Um,
there are techniques to correct for that
bias that should put our results at
least way more in line with the baseline
because there's no way possible this
should be underperforming.
So it's a combination of knowledge about
the algorithm, knowledge about various
techniques
and um just kind of looking at all this
stuff fresh and keeping it as simple as
I
markdown of the algorithm. I haven't
committed it at the moment. Um,
I suppose I can show it.
This is pretty much the current
algorithm.
It's mostly just these points here.
So you initialize a buffer with a number
of states.
Uh every time you do rollouts, you store
states to that buffer. You store the
advantage of those states during
training. And then every new um
rollouts, you sample some of the
environment states from that buffer uh
based on the advantage.
And then most of the questions are like
around how do we correct? Do we need to
correct for bias introduced by this
sampling? Do we need to do a Neil [ __ ]
so on and so forth.
Oh, alto. It's cool for now.
PC what
the sampling um it's prior it's the
prioritized replay sampling and then as
for correction the correction is just
going to be the basic like beta term in
important sampling and or annealing the
CL frack to zero So,
this is making progress, but it's just
not very good.
No, it has a literal meaning here. Um
the literal meaning is you're changing
the distribution of training data away
from like the distribution that you
expect training on environments from
scratch. Like the state set distribution
is different from your normal training
distribution.
It's the same thing as prioritized
advant uh prioritize experience replay
needs to correct
scheduler for the amount of
environments.
Um, a little different
the the research thing that you sent me.
I like that looks like it's LLM gen. Is
that LLM gen? I'm not just reading like
a massive LMG gen thing.
The heristic.
Huh? What's a heristic?
Also, how how close are we to done here?
Okay, 60% of the way done.
Yeah, this is not not great,
unfortunately.
I do wonder how much of this is just
going into the um
the buffer samples
because it's using like giant state
buffer.
Seems odd to me that it would do that.
That doesn't like the statement you're
making makes no like those words don't
go together.
We'll call this at least partially
reasonable. Um
I want to think about the stochastic
policy env.
What's a basic we have that can have
like an extended stochastic policy?
stochcastic policy. I'm I just I want an
end where the optimal policy is
stochcastic and non-trivial.
So like rock paper scissors, it's
stochcastic but it's trivial.
I don't think the optimal strategy is
stochcastic.
No, it's not. The optimal strategy in
blackjack is not stochcastic.
Package delivery. Why would that be
stochastic?
I have an old implementation of this. I
think I do.
because search massively [ __ ] blows
up your compute to the point that like
you can no longer do anything reasonable
at small scale.
searches like this huge [ __ ] massive
massive blow up in compute.
Adaptive enemy that with non-observable
strategy will do it.
Yeah, Jesse, that won't be stochastic.
That'll be deterministic conditioned on
the current OBS
is optimal.
right. Surely that bought us some time,
right?
It is getting better though, so I don't
really want to kill it.
I actually have no idea how hard poker
is.
I don't You don't need search for poker,
do you? I don't think so.
Um, go is very hard because Go has been
done with search with a [ __ ] ton of
compute.
Yeah, I think that there's still some
stuff to be done on the selfplay. Um the
sampling and stuff though, Jess.
No one brown says you need search
like need based on what
I don't believe that
like why the hell do you need search for
chess but you don't need search for dota
Uh
I mean but this is training on like a
GPU or a machine.
Dota is instinctive. No, it's [ __ ]
not. Are you insane?
Dota's a hell of a mix of different
stuff. That is a batshit hard
environment.
Yeah, I just I have not seen any version
of search that I've been convinced is
compute efficient. That's the problem.
Okay, cool. This is what we wanted.
Yeah, I've just I've not seen any
version of um of search I'm convinced is
efficient.
Like a lot of the like the fancy newer
search based things as well. Um,
the code for those is rough.
I am starting to believe we might need
to scale the model size a bit though for
some of these problems.
Well, it's funny cuz like
it's the results are very mixed.
Sometimes we just solve stuff with tiny
policies and then sometimes we have
problems that seem to need the capacity,
right? But just like this reminds me of
when people were doing all this crazy
ass theory of mind custom algorithm work
and then you look at Dota which very
clearly has theory of mind and it's just
a damn LSTM
you know
so do you actually need the fancy
algorithm to learn it or is it just
implicit
stuff like need is fundamentally compute
inefficient for GPUs,
uh, which rules it out almost instantly,
unless you're also designing the
hardware, which nobody's doing, and I
don't think it's promising enough to
merit that.
Oh, no. I believe chess is hard, Jess. I
believe chess is a hard problem.
Buffer four already sweeps the number of
layers for you.
I don't know about the weird con encoder
for chess though.
big just an embedding bag.
Interesting.
But like Jess, have you been I thought
isn't there this thing where you can't
repro some of the nice scaling results
from the con policy.
like stuff worked with the con policy
that doesn't work as well now.
I destroy my code base overnight. More
like it.
I'm trying to think what would be this
this thing,
right? But what's the point like what's
the point in it in having something
write a bajillion lines of code that
you're not going to be able to like
This is better than before, but still
it's like huge gap.
Lowest hook. Okay,
that's good.
Oh, the con policy might may have been
slightly worse. Okay, well that's good
then. If you don't need comms, it's way
better.
If you do need comms, then we have to
deal with [ __ ]
Oh, the thing is this is now
non-stationary, isn't it?
Is there a way to get a stochcastic
environment that isn't like crazy
non-stationary?
I mean without having to like you'd have
to pass your logits wouldn't you?
Our ppole doesn't have a stochastic
optimum policy.
Well, but the thing is we don't need to
make the best chest like bot in the
world, Jess.
Like, can you get 2k elo without search?
Yeah, Jess.
That's pretty cool.
That's very cool.
What do you think?
There's got to be a simple way to do
this, isn't there?
If it could see your logits, it would be
easier, wouldn't it?
Do we have any way to make it see your
logits?
I don't think we do, right? You just
pass the actions back.
Um, I want an environment
that is not non-stationary, that has a
stochastic optimal policy that's not the
uniform distribution.
Can you do that or do you only ever get
um stocastic policy like optimal policy
on non-stationary ends?
10 million params. We can definitely run
reasonably quick still.
The thing is a boss fight with random
timings arch that's still not a
stochastic optimum policy because it's
still deterministic conditioned on the
obs.
multi-stage prisoner. I still don't
think that's stochastic. Is that
optimum?
Particularly not against a static
opponent.
Maybe this is the right end. Maybe it's
just not learning correctly.
Poker. Yeah, you're giving these are
these are non-stationary because they
depend on other learn like other
distributions of opponents and learning
opponents and whatnot.
That is closer, isn't it?
If I do 200, does it like [ __ ] up?
Huh?
Oh, wait. Hang on.
I think that this works.
Um, the optimal policy of this env is a
little noisy, but it should be to play
action zero 75% of the time.
I think this is fine.
you don't have to play random against a
random opponent.
Okay, so we got memory stocastic. So, we
got the sanity ms. That's easy. We'll
clean them up and stuff, but um those
are nice to have.
And then the next state set thing as
soon as we have the current set of
results,
which I think we're fine on. I think we
can we'll go pull them in a second and
make sure. But I think that we have
enough of them that we can launch the
next set. Let me use the restroom. I'll
be right back.
I figured out how we're going to go
about this. We're going to make this a
little bit more interesting and um we're
not going to just be waiting around for
another sweep. All right, this is what
we're going to do.
Yeah. So, we have to go here and we have
to s SCP.
Oops.
Hey. Y [ __ ] terminal piece of [ __ ]
Yo, why does this break my terminal?
Huh? Microsoft.
This is on this is a Abuntu container on
WSL and then all the dev you've been
seeing me do is either on a 5090 Abuntu
machine or uh the 6GPU tiny box.
Okay. I mean, this is a little bit
closer at least,
particularly in steps, but yeah, it's
not great, right?
So, I guess what we're going to do now,
I mean, we can just take this. This is
the plan. We take this one here.
Jess, have you tried [ __ ] right off?
I don't feel like reinstalling this
desktop. It's got a bunch of old crap on
it and uh it's the summer and I like to
play a game of League once in a while.
Thank you very much.
Um, if you give me Dota that doesn't
have 10-minute lobby cues for new and
low elo players, then Sure.
I do mostly play Runescape crit. In
fact, here's the side monitor.
400k off 97.
How big were your sweeps when you did
more? Like I ran that stuff for days and
days, Spencer. I think most of the
experiments, it was like it was
thousands of experiments trying to find
better params for neural MMO and I
couldn't figure [ __ ] out.
Uh, yes, I tested that, Spencer, and
they are It's annoying.
That's the only thing I could think of,
right? Would be the uh the bias
See, this still underperforms, which is
ridiculous.
Okay, so this does not mess up training,
right?
Need something around the horizon of the
sets.
possibly even a little better than
before.
and then we get mid-range. So we don't
actually see the super high
prioritization
in here.
What about Beta?
Beta gets annealed.
Actually starts very high as well.
yield on what's being made here. This is
the next block of research for Puffer
Lib, which is a high performance
reinforcement learning library.
Uh this is currently algorithmic
research on
uh whether we can you whether we can set
simulators to specific states during
training in order to vastly improve
performance.
And I'm kind of running some experiments
on this password guessing environment
that I've kind that I've set up as a um
synthetic test benchmark.
That's a super quick version of what's
going on here.
Maybe this pryal alpha gives us a clue
of some sort, right?
the puffer on the left. That's our
mascot.
Okay. I mean, this is kind of
interesting, right? We get 225.
What do we get if I set this to zero?
I'm just curious.
You got to be kidding me. This thing
does just as good, if not better,
with no prioritization.
Really?
Ow.
Like what? Ow.
It takes 200 million bloody steps,
right?
The thing is like it's just weird to me
cuz this doing this makes a ton of sense
in my head.
I mean, this is the task where you would
do the CL, isn't it? But did I mess up
the task definition?
I mess up the implementation or the task
definition, let me think.
I guess you don't have the sampling
correction,
but I like you basically do the same
thing with the annealing.
A massive perf boost though, man.
Like,
okay. I mean, theory, right?
It just comes up with some wacko args.
let me just play with this a let me play
with this problem a little. It's usually
a waste of time to do this, but like
something is very screwy and I don't
understand what. We'll keep this
horizon.
Okay, so the default here just fails
instantly
with like no entropy.
That's interesting.
I wonder what it is that's like causing
that. We have this crazy entropy
coefficient.
Wait, it's determinizing very quickly
even with a 0.2 entropy.
Of course, you can't learn anything with
an entropy coefficient of one.
Why would it determin so quickly though?
Hang on. That's suspicious, isn't it?
I mean, I guess that's the problem.
Like, you know, you start
the hyper pram stuff is just so
powerful.
It's crazy that you just bol that with
hypers, man.
Let me double check.
It came up with like this task actually
just hard fails with defaults. It came
up with some crazy hypers that solve it
with the u the standard algorithm.
Hang on. I think I'm conflating [ __ ]
again.
Yeah. [ __ ]
It's the task death, isn't it?
I think this should work.
Actually, I think this end is fine the
more I'm thinking about it.
This is just a basic end for like
guessing a password. Um the point is
that like you have to restart from the
beginning every time you make a mistake.
So the point is that if you're doing
state sets and you get to start from
later into the puzzle or later into the
problem, it should be massively more
effective.
Stuff isn't working right. Very odd.
Well, I wonder. Hang on. Maybe we do
have like some weird boundary condition.
That's at least something.
And then we get entropy collapse
somehow, right?
But like the normal prim doesn't work.
>> Yeah. I mean, this is supposed to be a
clean test for Go Explorer.
is not doing it.
And then we have these screwy ass
hyperparameters that somehow solve the
whole task with no curriculum,
not even implicit.
but this is like not super meaningful
now, is it?
It doesn't even help on the like crappy
easy case.
This has got to be a 100% skill issue.
No.
this feels like we have some very deep
algorithmic problems honestly
and we're papering over them with
massive hyper hyper pram sweeps, but
those hyperp are being abused and not
used in the way they're intended.
Arch, this is now the fifth time this
has been brought up on the stream.
Benchmark works with crazy insane screwy
hyperparameters.
I'm not understanding this full-on
entropy collapse, though.
Okay, there. This end needs like stupid
high entropy. Sure.
That's at least like a reasonable
baseline, right
now. Let me see if I can do anything
from here.
Yeah, good enough. Arch.
We did get soda though is the thing with
it. There's there's signal in here
somewhere.
So [ __ ] man. Like why? If I take it
off, it works, right?
This matches. So the state sets are
fine.
No.
Well, then this just means the whole
thing is [ __ ]
Like,
what am I supposed to do with that?
There's no way that that should Oh, it's
just like super fiddly, huh?
Yes, there is Jess, but I'm annealing it
out over the course of training.
Okay, I suppose. Hang on.
What if I do this one?
I have a massive entropy coefficient on
it.
Yeah. See, now this does better with
absolutely no curriculum.
I mean this entropy coefficient is
already nuts. So,
I think we're conflating other stupid
problem setup things with the with the
actual task we care about
I mean cuz this is so obviously horribly
fiddly here, right?
Yeah, Jess, it gives really bizarre
results.
Like, it scales cleanly with compute,
but the hypers are insane.
Well, this is a waste of time. Let me
think what we can do.
There's basically no way in hell this
doesn't work.
I'm not going to go implement like a
much more complex and just
Like any of those work technically,
Jess. Yeah.
But I think you're basically the thing
is I think you just end up training a
perfect policy on the early levels of
that. It ends up being like enduro.
I mean 2048 is interesting for this,
right? But like that's too big of an
end. We should be able to get something
on a very clean
And I guess the structure of the obs
like there are a bunch of conflating
issues in here. Is there anything I can
do that's even cleaner than Yes.
We kind of do the full thing around
here.
No roll. So roll outs are
so rollouts are technically done async
but the training is synchronous.
the rollout workers are asynchronous
with each other but then the training
step is synchronous. So the data is
still on policy.
Okay, maybe we need to make
maybe we need to do more on this like
password end thing.
I think there's too much crap to
remember. Maybe
Um, it's a little more complicated than
that, just cuz that just that also
increases the amount of crap to
remember.
And everything I keep coming up with,
it's like, nope, that's going to be too
easy for the baseline.
What are we working on here?
This is um an algorithmic change that
relies on setting the simulator to a
specific state during training.
The goal is for like very long running
tasks where failure resets you. You
should be able to learn to automatically
resume at parts that you need to
practice.
I'm having a lot of difficulty coming up
with clean standalone tests. Um,
the problem is our base algorithm is
very good.
And two of the tests that I've come up
with so far that I thought would be
basically impossible, it just fully
solved after a hyperparameter sweep.
hyper plus I mean it's it's good to have
strong baselines right but it's just
like
I mean this thing you give it a bunch of
increasingly difficult mazes in a Oh,
and it basically gets soda.
See, what you need is you need a task
that like
it needs to take a while to do it. I
think.
Okay. You know what? The odds that I've
come up with are stupid here.
Yeah, the odds I've come up with are
stupid.
Too complicated, Spencer.
We need a simple test.
The thing that's stupid is like you're
just changing. It doesn't matter that
you tell the agent the passcode. It
can't learn. It's impossible for it to
learn an arbitrary copy function based
on that form. And basically, you're just
confusing it because you're changing a
very small portion of this state.
So, what you want basically is you just
you want an env that's not terribly
difficult to learn necessarily, but like
it requires some exploration to make
progress and then getting back to that
point takes a long time.
Okay, look. The obs are way better.
Yeah, those obs were way better.
Okay,
let's take the exploration crap off for
a second.
Why is that so freaking ludicrously
unstable?
The entropy is insane.
Hang on. Maybe
Yeah. Okay. So, the entropy loss is just
misleading here. It's very low because
like it's going to basically be zero up
until you get to a state you haven't
been in. So, okay. This is fine. This is
stable.
Okay, that's more like it.
Now, we'll see whether this is a fluke
or not, but that's what we would expect
out of CL.
Like, let me see if I set this to 1.0.
Let's first of all see if this is
unstable.
Okay, you know what? Fine. I'm I'm
willing to believe that this is too
aggressive. What about like 08? Is this
still fine or no?
If this is better, then I'm going to be
annoyed.
There's some more we need to
investigate.
Okay, you get something that's quite
weak without prioritization at all.
Now, if I put the state buffer stuff
back in,
what happens?
Not very many states. Maybe it's just
crushing training diversity.
It's all coming down to the stupid
entropy coefficient.
Yeah, there's something weird with the
entropy on this
These episode lengths are tiny.
I don't know why I'm like, am I
imbecile? Why am I testing with episode
length this small?
Okay, awesome. Val,
best of luck to you and uh there will be
cool things soon after. I will I will
handle stressing over figuring out what
the [ __ ] is wrong with this stupid
So
try something else.
I'm trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
like
Oh, I bet it could be the LSTM state
shed.
This is um Okay, we have to figure this
thing out like
Double check.
That would just be a straight bug that I
missed.
We still do have soda. There's something
here.
Isn't this how I did it for um
for pryo filtering?
Let's try this first and then double
check this against pryo. I think I might
have just misremembered how I did the um
filtering version.
This can't be a problem with the idea.
This has to be like a small
implementation thing because like
there's no way that you don't derive
benefit from state set.
Yeah, it's even worse.
There's a restroom. I'll be right back.
Okay, I got more ideas. I got more
ideas.
If this small change messes up the um
non-state based stuff.
I mean, the state sets for the end of
being broken would explain it for sure.
We have the chess training to um
I think he uh I don't think he PR the
encoder architecture though. Bet
like chess needs its architecture.
I'm trying to think what else would
cause that. It's kind of weird.
Uh, I'm testing state sets and
we had some really good results, but now
it's being fiddly.
I'm trying to create like an ideal test
end for it and I'm having trouble with
it.
I've gone through this several times,
but so we have the algorithm. Um, the
algorithm lets you save states of the
environment
and then restore them
in order to run the policy on them. So
the idea is that you store states, you
figure out which ones are high
information and then you jump to high
information states.
But we're having difficulty even under
the ideal case here. Even though we saw
like very good evidence from it before.
but something's off with either the
algorithm or what I'm doing or
something.
It's more than just prioritized replay.
It's state sets. We had prioritized
replay.
Now it's locked to four
and it learns a little bit at the end.
But I think something is just
implemented wrong. There's no way they
should possibly Oh, wait. No, that's the
original. The [ __ ]
We got soda on 2048
in literally the first thing that I ran.
Yeah.
And also it worked like
it worked in a it worked with
hyperparameters that were very strong
evidence yesterday. But the problem is
the hyper pram sweep stuff is like just
really good.
So now it's finding all sorts of crazy
hypers that make it work as just as well
with the original algorithm,
but it's kind of just obscuring the real
problems.
I'm trying to think what the hell this
would be.
that's fine. The same
We'll trust that from 3 0
If the main training is still crazy
unstable.
this is something
Maybe.
like this. The thing is this algorithm
should just crush. It should not even be
remotely close. Um,
it should just crush
I'm trying to figure out why. I mean,
this is the same thing we use for
prioritized experience replay.
Okay. So that'll probably uh hurt,
right?
I really don't care about the models,
but I'm trying to figure out the
problem.
See like the thing is this algorithm
it should be 10x better instantly.
any of this pushed? Uh, it will be
once I'm done making a mess.
Okay,
that's something
Just going to run it one more time to
see if it shifts it even more.
See if what happens when we do priority
in here.
Most likely this over samples and messes
it up somehow.
Okay. Okay. What happens if I don't
enneal the CL No.
million states probably also breaks.
Let's see.
So, I am, like I said, I'm doing more
stuff.
If we're [ __ ] this up, it would do
it.
That's the only thing I can think of,
though.
This should be so stable. Like what's
wrong?
Like this should just be incredibly
stable.
They should both be [ __ ] annealed is
the thing.
Like I would think that the correct
thing is this, this, and this, right?
This is so disappointing. Like, this
should just be the most powerful
technique ever immediately.
the
How did this get set to [ __ ] Seven.
Hang on.
No, it's just a typo.
Meant to type 0.7.
I'm going to go insane with this thing.
like just appending G to the start of
every [ __ ] file or prepending G.
That's not me hitting G. That's [ __ ]
Vim or whatever Windows terminal this
is.
Yeah, I know. That's just because the uh
this curriculum method is not optimized
yet.
If this thing gets 85 somehow out of the
box.
So if I just do like this,
for some reason it's a little unstable,
but this does work. 94
That's very heavy prioritization to be
There.
Yeah, that was it. That was stupid. Sam
fixed
It also gets less data at the start to
be fair with the CL on.
This thing breaks it, doesn't it? If I
just increase the size.
I thought we were done with this G
[ __ ]
I guess we do kind of just like go
through a lot of states.
I don't like that. But we'll try it real
quick.
Yeah, there's a lot of [ __ ] with this
algorithm.
The thing is this is in dev. Like it
should be very very stable in theory.
and it crashes.
Damn.
Works and then crashes.
shouldn't be anything with um
with the LSTM state, right?
Yeah, just that's um
a little high.
What could I have possibly screwed up in
this algorithm definition? And it seems
like it makes perfect sense. This
Do I need to run ablations on the
environment?
The um
stream is not exactly always G-rated
when I am frustrated, Bet.
right, here's what we do. Boom. Boom.
Boom.
This could just be a small model and
whatever the hell
The one reward in 32 steps is
reasonable.
Oh my gosh, I have created a [ __ ]
cult in the Discord. What is this?
Do I?
No, this is fine. Go.
Interestingly, the CL actually does do
better here.
I'm going to try this again with um much
shorter horizon.
And essentially what we're going to do
is we're going to hope that um the
we're going to essentially hope that
this like the batches were very low
signal because of the massive weights.
And it was looking fine. And it's just
unstable.
Why should that hurt? They really
shouldn't, right?
That should get you fresher data. If
anything,
I do too. Though I don't know if it's
just hypers being weird. The problem is
if I sweep.
Oh, Horizon 8 is probably just bad
because Um,
just very noisy I think
very difficult to draw conclusions
but um I do think there's something to
this.
Oh, hang on. You commented everything.
It should be like this, right?
No, this crashes, huh?
Super jumpy.
Maybe the incremental maze is better.
We'll see.
see about pryo alpha and beta.
This might be overkill.
They're getting better and they're still
stupid.
Well,
at least adding the curriculum here
didn't hurt.
Didn't help either, though.
I'm seeing like flashes of brilliance
and then it's broadly just not doing I'm
not seeing like the 10x that it should
be.
It doesn't matter. I decided I felt like
I didn't feel like giving Anthropic any
more money, so I'm all using Codeex to
You have a bunch of companies building
identical products.
Okay, a few more of these little
experiments we can do.
Do we do better?
Almost.
Okay, we get to 43.
Get to 44.
Get almost to 45.
Interesting.
Would that have worked without the
curriculum
or is curriculum
is this going to give us like a
replacement for um
Oh, but this is still prioritized. It's
just less prioritized, isn't it?
[ __ ] tattered stupid
file.
Um, anthropic has the very dangerous
combination of thinking that they're
very good people and being incredibly
out of touch.
So, it is possible we need to just
retune some hypers.
Yeah. So 41 which this is match.
Let's see what happens without
prioritization.
All right. So, we do this and we're
going to see. Does it just still get 41?
this is baffling to me.
Like
vamp support. I think that's how you do
it. arch. Unless
um Rayson doesn't have a native way to
do headless video, does he?
If he doesn't have a native way to do
it, then yeah, you just pipe it to f
ofmpeg.
I'm in um I'm in Palo Alta. This is an
old desktop and I don't feel like
reinstalling it. I'm on um I'm sshed
into uh Linux boxes for dev. Anyways,
got removed in 6.0. Oh, come on. Wait,
did he remove his gift saving thing?
I like that feature.
All right. Well, we'll have to open a um
open a thing on it. Like, that's the
best feature ever.
Well, I'm the only one who used it
because it's not like he doesn't
advertise that it exists anywhere.
Yeah, he literally posted about it once.
That's That's how I That's how I know it
exists.
Unless I remove this, but I'm pretty
sure we do with zero.
Yeah, FFmpeg will work. And then the
question will be whether we want it as
gifts or whatever.
Yeah, ffmpeg would be good.
And um and the fastest I believe there's
an example in puffer drive of like
piping it to f ofmpeg if you haven't
already done that.
All right, that's good. Arch,
I got to run to dinner in a few. I want
to finish my thoughts on this. It's like
this is going to bother the crap out of
me all night, I'm sure.
Um, I'm going to have to think about it,
Jess.
I don't understand how it is that like
we get from this to Yeah. Puffer just
solves it with no curriculum at all.
But then this is like weird because this
is a super curriculum heavy and or it
should be
Maybe incremental like incremental maze
is a new end and yeah it's based on my
old one but I don't like we shouldn't
have as much trust in this as we have in
our old end.
Thank you.
I'll continue to mess with this a little
bit folks. Um, I just want to try out
like the standard maze, um, with the
standard hypers and a few permutations
of adding curriculum to that
and we'll see what we get from that.
I mean the thing is that it really
really should give us a huge huge
difference in perf
and um the fact that like the implicit
pryo isn't like I know for a fact that
there were many maze at some time
included where this was a huge
difference but I guess it's possible
that our architecture just got
ludicrously stronger.
But we'll have to figure all that out
later. Um, in any event,
uh, for the folks who've been here all
day, thank you for tuning in.
We're going to still be doing this for
all this week, all next week.
Uh, right here. If you want to help me
out for absolutely free, Star the
Puffer, puffer.ai.
This number helps us out more than you'd
expect.
This means I don't have to spend my time
writing Twitter [ __ ] and advertising
and uh more companies just see puffer
and we get contracts and I spend more of
my time on R&D.
So go ahead and do that. Join Discord if
you want to get involved. Follow an X.